[Music]
if the pandemic proved one thing it's
that our economy is broken
the people who do the jobs we most
depend on had already suffered wage
stagnation and we're now most exposed to
covet on the front lines and to
financial hardship in the lockdowns
politicians everywhere are promising to
build back better
so now must surely be the time we try to
make our economy work for everyone
one idea for how to do so is universal
basic income or ubi
it's sometimes derided as free money for
the idea is that the government should
give everyone a regular amount of money
no strings attached so that they never
need to fear for their economic security
during the pandemic the u.s actually did
this and sent several checks to almost
everyone in the country
but checks in the mail forever may sound
ridiculous to you and the cost of it
even more so
certainly many academics and many of my
ft colleagues disapprove of basic income
we shouldn't be giving people a handout
because ultimately that doesn't help
them it's really the universality of it
that makes me very skeptical but i
believe there's more wisdom to ubi than
many people think
welcome to free lunch on film the series
where i take unorthodox economic ideas
that i like such as universal basic
income and put them to the test
[Music]
so ubi is an income a cash benefit it's
universal so it's given to everyone and
it's unconditional which means you don't
need to do anything in particular to
become eligible for it this seems
hopelessly radical even naive but it's
an idea with an amazing staying power
discussed for centuries from the
founding fathers of the u.s to today's
silicon valley tech billionaires from
u.s libertarians like milton friedman to
finnish socialists
i see that the universal basic income
would be a natural next step for the
nordic welfare state finland's
government has tested the policy and
they're not alone
india and south africa have considered
it iran's tried aversion there have been
ubi trials in the u.s canada the
netherlands kenya and many more places
but there's one place that gives a
better idea than all of these and that's
alaska
when oil tax revenue started coming in
40 years ago the state set up a
permanent fund to prevent politicians
wasting the money
every year it pays out a dividend
between one and two thousand dollars to
every man woman and child living in
alaska it was important and it was big
you know for us especially as a young as
a young family alex and kyra stewart
live in houma 220 miles from anchorage
they started out in fishing but now
supply wood to restaurants to flavor
grills and ovens
let me see
oh yeah deposit soa pfd division both of
them came in very good yep
they saved up the dividends they were
paid to their two girls
we homeschooled both of our children and
we used a portion of that savings that
the girls had to build their schoolhouse
so we could continue to school outside
of the kitchen table and then as the
girls got older it was it's just theirs
you know if they had a choir trip to go
on or you know they had money the
stuarts use their own dividends just as
sensibly so quite often in the past we
would use our dividend checks or
a dividend check to buy winter tires for
one of our trucks
sometimes if you're on the margins that
little bit is enough to pay the mortgage
or just give you some breathing room
often what we did when we had extra we
give to the local non-profits the local
museum the library even if it's a
thousand dollars to me
if i go and then spend that thousand
dollars in homer then that person have
got their dividend check but then they
just got another thousand dollars from
me and maybe a bunch of other people so
it really ripples out across the whole
community and they don't think the cash
stops people working
i just
like to think that people like
to work i mean people like to maybe they
would work in a different job maybe they
would not wash dishes but if they could
have the job they want instead of the
job they have to have and if they did
have a job that they liked but it wasn't
paying a lot
you know then they can still keep that
job but they do think a bigger dividend
could change that
i think there would be definitely a lot
more people that would opt to just you
know if they could just coast on the
dividend if say it was a thousand a
month you know and if there was two
people and then they had all their kids
if there's one thing the stuart's made
clear is that the dividend has given
them a greater sense of security and
well-being you know a thousand dollars
a year is not going to make or break you
know most people but knowing that we're
getting it is definitely a psychological
you know comfort it's not that much but
it saves your pride a little bit i guess
feels good to get something and i think
everybody can say that
[Music]
alaska's a special case but what the
students say goes to the heart of the
debate on universal basic income and
whether a similar or even larger payment
could make sense elsewhere
and i think they answer many of the
objections people have to ubi
what some people think is bad about ubi
is precisely what others think is good
about it
above all that there are no strings
attached to receiving basic income
to a conservative thinker like orin kass
that is a terrible idea the thing about
a ubi is that it's not how parents want
to raise their own kids most parents
don't tell their kids
don't worry whatever you do we're going
to take care of you and give you enough
money to live on every year
but they won't have any say about it
whether they want the kids to receive it
or not in america it'll be like having
your crazy uncle sam come charging
through the door
telling the kids don't worry what your
parents say i'm going to take care of
you as you turn 18 work if you want
don't work travel and smoke
i've got your back
so why give out money unconditionally
well one reason is that the welfare
systems we have today are just too
complex a lot of poor people who are
eligible and should be getting the
benefits aren't juana marinesco has
studied ubi trials as well as the alaska
dividend the one thing that a universal
benefit would be able to achieve is to
avoid leaving behind people who should
be eligible but
due to administrative complexities were
unable to avail themselves of the
benefit
politicians who support ubi like
finland's social affairs minister hannah
sarkidan also believe our welfare
systems have to be updated to support
more digital and precarious working
lives
people are not so clearly workers or
entrepreneurs or unemployed or studying
they might be that all mixed together
and maybe our current social security
system is not really flexible enough
not everyone on the left agrees with
satkin and socialist party ubi is not
finnish government policy at the same
time not everyone on the right disagrees
it was a previous center-right
government that set up a two-year ubi
trial it paid 2 000 unemployed people
560 euros a month the trial showed that
people when they have the universal
basic income
they are more satisfied with their life
and they feel that their income is more
stable and protected
the findings also went against the
belief that unconditional money weakens
the incentive to work
you
see from the finnish trial
that people didn't
work less
so having the universal basic income
didn't mean that people would
stop looking for jobs and stop being
active in their life
that finished result has held up
elsewhere
people don't seem to use unconditional
money irresponsibly or work less
in many studies there is no effect on
work at all
and in some studies there is some
decrease in work but it tends to be very
small
and what matters isn't just whether a
basic income will keep people working
but whether their jobs would be better
this times with the experience of the
stewards in alaska who described how
their dividend
liberates people and that to me is one
of the greatest attractions of basic
income
when people don't live on the edge they
enjoy more freedom of choice and suffer
less stress financially and
psychologically they can more easily
afford to say no to exploitative jobs or
have time off to retrain and learn new
skills they can reduce paid work to care
for young children or elderly parents or
even take the risk of starting up for
themselves
but not everyone is convinced by
small-scale trials
the experiments that are run are very
short and time-limited for a small
number of people so it's not actually a
test of how people would behave in a
society where they grow up knowing the
program is there
and yes knowing basic income will always
be there could make people less keen on
paid work
because the person has more
opportunities to do something outside of
work they might want to work less
especially if the job they're doing
isn't very good
being able to leave bad jobs is not a
bad thing though it could force
employers to treat workers better
and remember what the steward said about
the alaska dividend which has been
around for 40 years when it's spent it
creates jobs
[Music]
all this cash is going to be spent
in local businesses in restaurants in
retail and that creates jobs and so you
have a phenomenon where maybe people
want to work a bit less but companies
want to hire more people and it turns
out that these two effects work in
opposite directions and therefore you
could see no effect once you introduce
ubi at scale that's why i don't think we
need to worry a lot about the work
incentives over ubi
but skeptics have another worry they
doubt that those who lose their jobs or
are poorly paid because of automation
and digitalization can really benefit
from a ubi just giving people handouts
doesn't solve the problems that come
with being out of work
particularly the way ubi is being spoken
about in silicon valley they're saying
hey let's just go to the midwest and
hand laid off factory workers a check
and they're gonna be fine they can go up
and be poets and painters doesn't work
like that guys work has meaning well i
agree with that but i still think that
if you are out of work you're much
better off with a ubi than without one
now opponents still worry that without
conditions on the money some people will
just waste it
i think that's a prejudice not rooted in
the facts
they just spend it on everyday expenses
the rent the food you know just like you
would spend any extra income
certainly this is what we see in alaska
where the cash largely seems to be spent
well alex and cairo have used it to buy
fuel and winter ties
but critics say the alaska dividend is
too small to draw any conclusions
the size of the payment is not something
that actually is designed to
uh or could support a family
that's a good point so let's look at
another us case with much more money in
north carolina the eastern band of
cherokee indians gets huge revenues from
a casino on their reservation and they
hand this out unconditionally to all
members of the tribe just like a ubi it
averages four to six thousand dollars a
year much more than alaska
the effects were quite remarkable first
of all increase the educational
attainment of kids by one full year
among the poorest members of the tribe
secondly the dividend reduced mental
health issues among the kids and in
particular it reduced drug and alcohol
abuse which i think is very interesting
because a lot of people when you tell
them about ubi they're worried that
people will spend it on drug and alcohol
and this study shows that it's exactly
the opposite well i find all this pretty
reassuring people spend free money
sensibly and they don't stop working
but there is another objection
why on earth would you want to give it
to the rich
[Music]
that's what bothers melissa kearney an
economics professor who studies
inequality
the idea that we're going to be paying
transfer payments to a universal set of
people people all up the income
distribution with very little social
return for that that's what doesn't make
any sense to me
i could come up with a lot better uses
of taxpayer dollars subsidized child
care low-income rental support
unconditional cash assistance to
families with kids but supporters have a
reason for giving ubi to everyone
including the rich it's that if you
means test the benefit only for the
poorest you penalize people just when
they manage to do better
as they become less poor their benefits
get cut off and so that both provides a
disincentive to work but also frankly
could be seen as unfair as people are
slightly bettering themselves we are
clobbering them
and so the whole point of a universal
basic income is that since the cash is
the same for everybody even if you're
working more you're still receiving your
benefit so if we really want to reward
work we should let people keep their
cash when they're successful even
opponents agree with this point
you're right that the case to be made
for extending it up the income
distribution is then you don't distort
people's decisions whether or not you go
to work you get this check that's a good
thing so it really depends on how much
spending we want to put towards this
program
[Music]
so here we come to one of the biggest
issues is ubi even affordable a small
payment like alaska's doesn't make
enough of a difference so i'm interested
in whether we could have a generous ubi
that would provide a real safety net
but the headline cost seems terrifyingly
high
a meaningful ubi something like ten
thousand dollars per adult in the us
would cost about 2.5 trillion dollars
that is more much more than we spend
right now on all redistributive programs
so if we wanted to pay for something of
this magnitude something that could cost
five to ten percent of gdp we'd have to
give up social security we'd have to
give up disability insurance
to me that's a very strange view of what
the government should be doing to help
its citizens
well i think we can find better ways to
fund a ubi if we see it in connection
with a tax system rather than as simply
swapping one benefit for another well of
course we cannot look at basic income as
a separate conversation
we would make the changes to the
taxation system and
take the money away from the rich people
let's work through a hypothetical
example of a generous basic income
suppose we wanted to pay all adults one
third of what the average british
household has to spend per head
that would be about 7 000 pounds a year
i would implement this as a deduction
from your monthly taxes
a deduction that could be refunded so
that if you didn't owe any tax you would
get the whole amount paid out in cash
on a gross basis that would cost about
18 of national income
but a ubi would allow us to make big
savings elsewhere for example the basic
state pension is about seven thousand
pounds a year
if the elderly instead received the same
amount as a ubi the government could
save five percent of national income
and currently people earn large amounts
of money before they start paying tax
and this is worth more to high earners
who would otherwise face higher tax
rates
with a ubi paid as a flat tax deduction
to everyone
we could charge income tax from the
first penny earned
in the uk this alone would free up
another eight percent
so in our example just those two
measures would leave us with a much
smaller net funding gap of five percent
of national income
that's still a big amount to be sure but
as finland's hana sarkinen says it's an
amount we could realistically consider
raising in taxes
[Music]
what this means is that ubi is not a
utopian idea but a serious proposal for
social reform that can be seriously
debated
[Music]
such a debate will turn not just on the
trials and the evidence but on how you
view human nature and the role of
government
well in my mind ubi is a bad idea
because it says it is the responsibility
of the government to support everybody
instead of people's responsibility to
support themselves we see people as a
subject that want to be active want to
work want to improve their lives and
also i think we
trust people more
maybe this is an ideological divide that
just can't be bridged
even so i believe there is more
agreement than it appears at first
i think in theory if you could say
actually
implementing a universal basic income
would not change how people think about
work those would be very good counter
arguments to what i'm saying and here's
another idea
could we get the critics more on board
if we don't call it a ubi intended to
let people choose not to work but
something more like a dividend from
shared resources it could be alaska's
oil the cherokee's casino profits big
tech data extraction or a carbon tax
i like it and in fact california is in
some ways already doing this they're
saying look we are going to tax data
collectors and then we're going to hand
it back to the the individual or via the
state to the individual and i think in
the u.s given that california tends to
lead policy you may see it taking flight
nationally at some point
and something else everyone agrees to is
that we should avoid penalizing people
for working more or bettering their
situation
so people who don't agree on ubi as a
final destination for reform could
perhaps agree on some of the specific
building blocks that make up ubi
i see
basic income
as a road and i'm not sure whether we
will ever get there but i see that
taking steps towards basic income we can
improve and renew our our current social
security system and make it more
flexible
make it more simple
better for the people
universal basic income is still an
unorthodox idea and a lot of people
think the proposal just goes too far
but the pandemic has made citizens and
politicians more prepared to consider
truly radical reform
i believe the time for ubi is drawing
near
[Music]
and finally we'd love to hear what you
think so please share your comments